Michael Lacey and James Larkin built a
newspaper Empire devoted to exposing
corruption in politics and exposing
things where business and government
were colluding when the newspaper
industry collapsed they launched a new
venture that inadvertently changed the
sex work industry turning them into
villains and a new moral crusade
backpage.com is nothing more than a
front for pimps and child sex
traffickers there are more slaves in the
world today than ever before in human
history it is a crime that is rightly
punishable by incarceration in prison
this is about people creating careers
building names for themselves piss in my
mouth but don't tell me it's raining
criminalized the industry throw us in
jail but don't tell me they're trying to
save us and make it better it was a
McCain production you know that
committee is the progeny of the house on
American Activities Committee Joe
McCarthy's committee in the 50s coming
up how the crackdown on one website
turned back the clock on the sex work
industry and had profound consequences
for free speech on the Internet it would
give the lie to our entire lives
our entire career of being journalists
if the government could come in and put
their stubby little fingers in our chest
and make us ask for our mom ain't going
to happen
[Music]
federal agents raiding the home
belonging to one of back pages
cofounders federal investigators were on
seeing their vehicles lining the highway
here behind me on April 6 2018 the FBI
raided the homes of backpage.com
founders Michael Lacey and James Larkin
they were accused of running a website
that facilitated prostitution reports
hailed their arrests and indictment as a
major victory in the battle against
modern sexual slavery on the Internet so
who are these two men and how did they
end up as defendants in the biggest
prostitution trial in the last decade
Michael Lacey and James Larkin met
almost 50 years ago in Tempe Arizona
Michael Lacey was a student at Arizona
State University and him and some other
students they are founded this paper the
New Times in 1970 journalist Elizabeth
Nolan Brown writes about sex workers and
the criminal justice system and she's
been covering the lawsuit against
Backpage it was an anti-war paper it was
a response to the shootings at Kent
State and various other sort of student
activism happening at the time James
Larkin came on about a year or so later
morons with typewriters we had no guy
did an idea of what we were doing none
of us had ever put out a newspaper or
taken any journalism class we were like
a number of 20 year olds full of
confidence because we didn't know any
better New Times was focused on the
reader wasn't focused on the power
structure wasn't pandering to anyone but
basically was pandering to the
readership in terms of interesting
stories attitudes that were not
right-wing and not left-wing but kind of
unusually anachronistic
by 1972 the two had dropped out of
college and started an alternative
newspaper New Times weekly which
eventually became phoenix new times over
the years they focused their voice on
challenging established interests an
anti-authoritarian attitude but not just
needlessly so I mean they were sort of
devoted to exposing corruption in
politics and exposing things where
business and government were colluding
but also with a sort of playful attitude
to that led to battles with powerful
people in Arizona like John McCain we
had an immediate issue with McCain
everything to this guy was communist
strong country supporter McCain was a
new politician at the time who had
married his wife Cindy there Sydney
McCain's dad is part of a sort of
wealthy liquor baron family there so
their whole family and his connections
had been targets of new time for a long
time then there was the notorious
Arizona Sheriff Joe Arpaio
who was later convicted of being in
contempt of court over locking up
immigrants who didn't have a legal
status we went after what happened to
prisoners once they went into the jail
there was a higher incident of violence
and casualty and sickness and death we
also wrote about his racism and his
campaign against people with brown skin
they were just really over the years
developing a lot of enemies from these
people in power and that extended beyond
Arizona as they moved into other cities
and started doing journalism through
their papers their their willingness to
take on powerful interests meant that
they were constantly getting sued or
suing other people over access because
the paper was immensely profitable their
legal bills became just a cost of doing
business revenues derived almost
exclusively from classified ads you know
usually took up the back pages and pages
of these free weekly newspapers
obviously you have things like how
wanted job ads and for rents the
personals were a huge part of back page
ads and then also there were adult ads
escort ads phone sex line ads strip club
reviews and all of that the model that
we kind of tinkered with started in
Greenwich Village
going back to 1955 of the Village Voice
okay they started with classifies with
adult ads with stripper ads all kinds of
in the back of the book totally legal
always have been legal it's not a
johnny-come-lately business so all
through the 70s 80s and 90s all of our
papers carried adult and those are
things that sustain not just the phoenix
new times in the papers that Lacey and
Larkin own but all of these alt weekly
is across the country for so long
meanwhile Lacey and Larkins newspaper
business was extremely lucrative so by
the 80s and especially the 90s they were
able to start buying up these all
weeklies that were failing in other
cities and by the early 2000s they had
more than a dozen different papers in
different cities including in Los
Angeles and Miami and Dallas and then a
new player entered the classified game
with the potential to bring down Lacey
and Larkins all weekly Empire
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 1995 a computer programmer in San
Francisco started publishing a
classified listing service on a
communication platform that was just
starting to get mainstream attention an
online network called Internet people
started asking me if I could put jobs
there stuff for sale and it just wound
up growing in a way out of control
Craigslist could help you find
everything from an apartment to
furniture to a date in their personal
section it was everywhere and it was
serving everyone Craigslist destroyed
the the daily and the weekly newspaper
business by the early 2000s that had
bitten into the revenues of almost every
newspaper in America we start to feel it
in San Francisco in about 98 99 and we
decided we'd better do something about
it so 2004 we launched backpage.com
which was the descendant of our back
page of them our newspapers all of our
newspapers had a back page that was
called that page there are different
sections just like in the print for jobs
and gigs and community fliers and people
selling things and then there was an
adult ad section strippers and for
escorts and for phone sex things and all
sorts of sex work and adult
entertainment that is legal illegal
activity wasn't allowed according to
back pages Terms of Service from the
beginning they had filters and monitors
that checked for things on their site to
make sure that people weren't abusing
the practice but sex workers forge their
own way just as they had in the alt
weekly classifieds through innuendo
hi-tech call girls choose their words
carefully to send the message without
overstepping legal bounds most people
will probably say that I'm a prostitute
or they might call me a high-class
escort is more of the sex industry moves
to the Internet and possibly away from
people's lives so that they're not
bothered by brothels or street
prostitution you all see less of an
interest in it as far as law enforcement
go
[Music]
Backpage allowed Lacy and Larkin to keep
publishing as other papers went under in
2005 they acquired the original alt
weekly The Village Voice which had set
the standard for fearless reporting on
the misdeeds of the powerful with it's
classified revenues decimated the paper
was in danger of folding Lacy and Larkin
saw an opportunity to integrate what was
left into back page we wanted everything
this is what we did for living we were
Weekly journalists who told magazine
style stories and in my humble opinion
did it better than anybody else and then
they started making partnerships with
other people and it started really
expanding and then you know eventually
instead of expanding across the world
[Music]
I've rescued over 10,000 American
children from prostitution I have seen
the underbelly of the sexual
exploitation of children and babies for
over 40 years nothing surprises me
anymore Lois Lee is the founder and
director of children of the night a
program that helps underage sex workers
looking for a way out the motorists on
fabled Sunset Boulevard will find most
Hollywood intersections equipped with a
traffic light and a prostitute she
started her outreach efforts in
Hollywood in the late 1970s outside of
motels at pickup spots on the classified
pages of alt weeklies and at diamond
dance clubs we Chum meet up to the
owners and they'd let us talk to the
girls so we're all controlled by pimps
so I've been part of that underworld I
know the players they know me I'm well
respected the crack epidemic and
subsequent drug war of the late 1980s
and early 1990s made working the street
more dangerous I had Street teams and we
were bulletproof vest and I finally
closed those Street teams in 1990
because there was just too many
shootings there's really more concerned
about picking up the stray bullet
because we were writing up and finding
dead bodies in the street and we'd be
like right next to the police when this
is being discovered so the street
activity started to disappear then the
internet came
on the streets you'd get $40 and you're
gonna get raped robbed and beaten up on
the internet you would meet a doctor or
a lawyer or a movie star or a singer and
you would get $300 for the same sex and
you were safer
let's see well um you know don't send
your daughters to college they'll learn
about feminism and labor rights and then
they'll become [ __ ] which is what
happened to me Suzy Q graduated from a
liberal arts college right after the
2008 financial crisis and the 2008 job
market was not great for my Bachelor of
Arts degree and I was working a retail
job I was hungry in San Francisco in
2008 was not making ends meet in college
she had been assigned real live nude
girl by dr. Carol Queen a writer and
activist in the sex positive feminists
movement the book was partly set at San
Francisco's lusty lady theater and I
knew that that peep show that I had read
about in college was just up the hill it
was my first job in the adult industry I
loved it I was immediately on the board
of directors as the theater coordinator
so I was I was doing activism I was
running a business and I was also
dancing naked for money and I've just
never stopped Suzy Q was a part of a new
generation of sex workers entering an
industry transformed by the Internet
well eventually strip club money who was
cool and all but cost of living was just
continuing to skyrocket and I started
doing other types of sex work erotic
massage domination and of course my red
book was integral to that by eliminating
the need for pimps as middlemen the
internet empowered sex workers on a
whole new level so I could ask for a
reference or ask for you know it's just
starting up at the time but LinkedIn
profiles you know can you verify that
you are who you say you are there was
also a section of the website called my
pink book that was for workers only so
everything from hey I don't want my
massage table anymore it's like a pre
Facebook marketplace for hoes or oh my
god this guy robbed me here's his photo
put it on your blacklist these informal
ways of sharing information building
community were ways that we kept safe
[Music]
in 2002 President Bill Clinton signed
the victims of trafficking and violence
Protection Act which defines sex
trafficking and made it a federal crime
under federal law in order for something
to be sex trafficking and it has to be
an element of force fraud or coercion
involved or someone has to be underage
president george w bush picked up where
clinton left off directing money to
anti-prostitution groups mostly
christian groups but you've started to
see all prostitution is being described
as sex trafficking or human trafficking
and at that time they start these giant
stings that mostly rely on craigslist
and later Backpage and this really
starts picking up under obama but the
FBI funding these task forces with local
sheriffs and giving them money sort of
contingent on the fact that they frame
these as sex trafficking stings instead
of prostitution stings and they're
really combining to make it look like
there's a huge epidemic in this huge
problem that needs to be addressed
there was also operation cross country a
federal law enforcement initiative to
stop sex trafficking that's been running
for more than a decade most of those
arrested were consenting adult sex
workers and their customers juveniles
that they do find which are you know
almost all older teenagers sixteen and
seventeen they often end up arresting
them and they do offer them some sorts
of services usually but it's conditioned
on them testifying against someone and
you know claiming and naming a
trafficker that they can go after
instead then they just take the people
and take them back to wherever they came
from if that was foster care or you know
a state home or their parents house
wherever a lot of times they're you know
already people who are in troubled
situations and so they're you know
running away from those and trading sex
just sort of to get by on their own by
2010 anti sex work activists began to
sharpen their messaging I am very much
engaged in stopping the purchasing of
illegal sex sexual exploitation and I do
it by being an activist a Texas oil
heiress named swanee hunt founded demand
abolition a nonprofit dedicated to
destroying the illegal sex trade except
that prostitution between consenting
adults doesn't really make that many
people angry anymore in the United
States
in 2010 Hunts Group commissioned a
report that suggested rebranding
prostitution as sexual slavery because
doing so might garner more support and
less resistance is a really good way to
describe it the sex slavery trafficking
business today this sexual enslavement
going on lost children trapped into sex
slavery in 2010 a coalition of state
attorneys general went after Craigslist
anyone looking for adult services on
Craigslist will have to go elsewhere a
company shut down that section 17 state
attorneys general recently sent a letter
to the website saying the adult services
section promotes prostitution and child
trafficking although that's still feared
all over the rest of Craigslist they
just usually mostly shift it into the
dating site but also a big share of the
market did go over into back page then
and that was when the attorneys generals
started doing the exact same thing that
they did with Craigslist - back page and
saying hey you've got to take down this
adult ad section in 2010 people began to
sue back pages parent company claiming
they'd been trafficked on the site they
weren't saying the back page knew that
they were underage or even necessarily
should have known but that by virtue of
them having provided this platform where
it was possible for other people to have
posted ads for them then back page was
culpable so you're just saying no
because there's the same section 230 of
the Communications Decency Act passed
90s and it says the web platform
shouldn't be treated as the speakers of
content which basically means websites
digital platforms you know cloud
services search engines all of that
they're not liable for every single word
that users put up and they're not
treated as sort of one in the same
legally with their users the lawsuits
were dismissed on the grounds that
section 230 absolved back page from
culpability so anti sex worker activists
shifted their strategy Ashton Kutcher
and Demi Moore do this real men don't
buy sex campaign there are more slaves
in the world today than ever before in
human history tapping the United States
is between 100 and 300 thousand child
sex slaves in the United States today
the number ran everywhere I ran the New
York Times I ran in USA Today with a CNN
damn media outlet took and accepted this
while ever looking at the source
material a cover story in the Village
Voice revealed that the statistic was
taken out of context specifically look
at this University of Pennsylvania's
story that's where this hundred thousand
three hundred thousand number comes from
they traced it back to a two thousand
one journal article estimating that
there were 100,000 to 300,000 children
deemed at risk for sexual exploitation
in the US Canada and Mexico not just the
United States as Kutcher and others had
claimed that would be six thousand
underage children being sex trafficked
in America's 50 largest cities it was
totally junk science
The Voice also found out that the
study's methodology was flawed because
it's figures weren't based on actual
cases the authors relied on guesses at
who might end up a sex trafficking
victim and the data was more than 12
years out of date by the time Kutcher
and others were citing it even the
crimes against children Research Center
advised journalists and researchers in
2008 not to cite the study one of the
study's lead authors later said the same
Ashton Kutcher freaks out he has this
total Twitter meltdown he starts
tweeting at the Village Voice and saying
that they support child sex trafficking
and you know everyone should boycott
them it's like a bar fight you know and
you just can't see where the next idiot
is going to come from you just know that
they're coming and it's like a bar fight
that never ends backpage.com
is nothing more than a front for pimps
and child sex traffickers to stop this
online child sex trafficking that's
being facilitated by sites such as this
but we need to approach this as if this
were your daughter or your niece or your
neighbor who's being victimized by
Backpage and other people like that
they've all really simplified what is a
hugely complicated issue and they've
made it into a thing where it's there is
one website it is permitting child sex
trafficking and section 230 is a
loophole that lets it none of that is
true but that was sort of the narrative
that got settled on around 2011 or so
it's an evergreen political issue always
works those guys are there waiting to be
governors or senators presidents that's
what that was all about who could be
opposed to them to take on child sex
trafficking
well we're opposed to them and we're
gonna fight this we'll talk about this
so in 2012 Laci and Larkin sell the
papers to a group of their current
executives that work for them and they
move over to exclusively running back
page at the time back page was bombarded
with lawsuits for Laci and Larkin this
was familiar territory much like when
they were fighting these battles with
their papers before this they keep
winning because the law is on their side
and they're not doing anything illegal
they're actually succeeding in court but
that changes I guess the more you have
more and more people pile on
in 2012 California Attorney General
Kamala Harris took an interest in
Backpage backpage.com needs to shut
itself down when it has created as its
business model the profiting off the
selling of human beings and the purchase
of human beings Harris had supported
anti-sex trafficking bills when she was
District Attorney of San Francisco and a
state attorney general she also served
on an anti trafficking task force in the
state good businesses such as Craigslist
understood how it could be misused and
mishandled and they shut that aspect of
their business model down back [ __ ]
needs to do the same leadership and
founders all along we're like tell us
what we can do to actually eradicate
exploitation in our sight tell us we can
actually do to help you but we're not
gonna just take down this thing to
better understand the issue in 2012
Lacey and Larkin visited children of the
Knights facility and met with Lois Lee
we spent the day because we heard about
the work that Lois was doing a lot of
the NGOs around this issue raise money
to raise money to raise money and
awareness somewhere fits in there and
the problem is with that is that there's
no one on the ground helping these kids
Lois
fits that bill and we were surprised to
find her because we haven't found
anybody we've been in this building for
25 years it's a 24 bed facility there
were 3,000 68 children who lived here
they attended an on-site school we put
hundreds of kids in college we have a
multitude of things that we do from head
to toe for a long period of time with
kids for instance some are being
assessed for individual educational
plans because of learning disabilities
and you have to have counseling and you
got rape trauma Lacey and Larkin spent
the day observing the program here is a
woman who's trying to do something about
this and we wanted to see if we could
help and I said why need money because
I'm carrying a hundred thousand dollar
accounts payable that I've got to take
care of Lacey and Larkin have donated
nearly a million dollars to children of
the night since 2012 they also gave the
organization free ad space
at least urging employees for Backpage
trained vice cops on how to use the site
to catch would-be traffickers like if
they see a guy take a girl into a motel
they can't necessarily go in that motel
room without probable cause but could
they call Backpage to get the guys ID
and see if he's a parolee and and get
his credit card information identify who
he is and they said we would be happy to
do that
the Vice cops loved it and they used it
and they called them all the time it was
totally cooperative we really had a good
relationship with DOJ we had a good
relationship with Bob Waller in 2011
then FBI director Muller awarded a
Department of Justice certificate to
lacy Larkins top deputy Backpage CEO
Karl Ferrara for helping with federal
sex trafficking investigations local law
enforcement agencies also privately
commended the company for its
outstanding cooperation compared to
other companies and for being law
enforcement friendly they made numerous
arrests but we're told by their upper
echelon the Chiefs you cannot tell
anybody and we don't want to know about
it because you have to understand that
police departments get their money from
Congress so the pressure really wasn't
about police because it was a wonderful
you know investigative tool it was
really politics in 2013 forty nine
attorneys general petitioned Congress to
amend section 230 of the Communications
Decency Act so that they could bring
criminal charges against Backpage
Congress declined to pass legislation so
politicians and law enforcement began to
target Backpage by any means necessary
today with an overwhelming bipartisan
vote the United States House of
Representatives passed the save act he
was explicitly sold by sponsor and
Wagner and various other politicians as
a way to hold Backpage accountable it
was the first attempt though where they
were gonna change section 230 around
this time the site had to defend itself
on another front Cook County Illinois
Sheriff Tom dart came up with the idea
of pressuring Visa and MasterCard to
stop processing payments on the site
card companies that are accepting
Backpage payments that they cannot do
business with back page or he will come
after them the company sued and a
federal judge declared darts actions
unconstitutional but despite the winds
Backpage was racking up in court
politicians began to narrow in on the
site going
after people associated with it in the
most public ways possible in 2015 a
Senate subcommittee held a hearing on
Backpage but by this time Laci and
Larkin had sold a company to Karl
Ferrara and weren't involved in the
direct business of publishing or
advertising any more lawmakers demanded
Ferrara appear before them to answer
questions and subpoenaed company
documents he didn't come to the hearing
and his attorneys told Congress he was
out of the country at the time today not
only as your attorney general but as a
proud California candidate for the
United States Senate in October 2016
Harris joined Texas Attorney General Ken
Paxton and filed criminal charges
against Farrar Lacy and Larkin Farrar
was arrested on pimping charges and lacy
and Larkin were charged with conspiracy
to commit pimping she does this right
before the election and she knows she
doesn't have the authority because she's
already asked Congress please can I have
the authority and even though she
doesn't have it and they don't give it
to her
she arrests us anyway and inside the
courtroom there was a jail cell they
filmed us in the jail cell and then
broadcast it on the evening news so
Harris gets to have her name in all the
papers right before the election saying
that she's the one who helped take down
these people that everyone for years has
been characterizing as these big evil
sex traffickers it was a publicity stunt
lacy and Larkin spent four days in a
Sacramento jail she knew the section 230
barred her from bringing these charges
but she brought them anyway and of
course a judge threw them right out so
Harris filed another set of charges
against the three men Harris was trying
to say that drawler and lacy and Larkin
by virtue of having the sight and
knowing that sometimes you know bad
things happen there that they were
guilty these other pimping charges later
get dismissed - the judge did allow a
separate money-laundering charge to
proceed but Harris had recently been
elected the new junior senator from
California and was about to join the
permanent Subcommittee on investigations
which had already been working on
compelling lacy
Larkin Farrar and other Backpage
employees to testify before Congress
they did so on January 10 2017 the day
before the hearing Backpage closed the
adult personal ad section of the website
the
purpose of the hearing was to determine
whether Backpage staff had knowingly
edited user posts which would deprive
them of legal protection under Section
230 brought forward defending ourselves
in court
mr. Larkin don't you still exercise
substantial direction and control over
back page after consultation with
counsel I decline to answer your
question based on that rights provided
by the first and fifth amendment
senators blast backpage.com executives
in a tense and emotional hearing to be
clear this is a crime it is a crime that
is rightly punishable by incarceration
in prison we don't remember learning
that instructions to cover up a crime
our protected speech you acknowledged
today for the record the child sex
trafficking is a serious problem on
Backpage it was just like one more
moment of political drama where Claire
McCaskill got to ask all these
rhetorical questions
according to Lacey and Larkin the
hearing provided an opportunity for the
McCain family to get revenge for
critical coverage in the new times
decades earlier
John McCain was there and Cindy McCain
was there it was a McCain production you
know that committee is the progeny of
the house on American Activities
Committee Joe McCarthy's committee in
the 50s and that is a permanent
Subcommittee on investigations and what
they do is traipse people in front of
them for political gain and to promote
agendas that are particularly
interesting or fruitful for those
politicians would you agree with that
yeah that's what a dog and pony show the
next month - you have Ashton Kutcher
comment get called to testify as a sex
trafficking expert before Congress I
also want to thank ELISA an Ashton
Ashton you we're better-looking in the
movies that anyway dad yeah
it's a charade it's an absolute charade
you can vilify these two guys for all of
the sins in the world and that's what's
happening you know it's not right behind
these gates of this Paradise Valley
Community
federal agents raiding the home
belonging to one of back pages
co-founders the feds also raiding the
homes of the other co-founder today the
federal government sees the website
backpage.com now non-existent now shut
down by the feds I was on a plane from
the UK
I'd been on a hiking trip with my son 12
masked and armed FBI agents stormed to
my house terrorized my daughter in her
bedroom and they took as the search
warrant suggested anything of value so
cars jewelry then they arrested me
later that afternoon on the tarmac at
the airport salvinia work was they just
decided they terrorized my family send a
message their response to our offer to
surrender was to say no we're gonna come
and get him when we won and that's
exactly the attitude that was on display
when they showed up at my house I
detected some sort of movement I looked
over and as a guy pointing a gun at me
and I go out and they're all heavily
armed handcuffed my arms behind me they
want to know if anybody else is on the
property and I said yes my mother-in-law
is here where is she and I point out
where she was in the shower I said why
don't we just go down there together and
I'll bring her out so there's no
additional drama and he wouldn't do that
he said how she's treated will depend
entirely upon how she responds she's a
woman who's almost 80 years old an FBI
agent with the gun drop burst through
the door and she is naked and she asked
for a towel and the guy said when an FBI
agent tells you to do something you do
it anything that they could perceive as
mine they took so they took art they
took all of my wife's jewelry you know
they drove off
my truck they drove off my car Sydney
McCain today she said quote Backpage has
caused immeasurable suffering and pain
or John McCain just tweeted this is an
important step forward in the fight
against human trafficking former sheriff
joe arpaio even went after the pair
today telling ABC 15 he's happy the
federal government is taking action Lacy
and Larkin were charged with
facilitating prostitution through a
federal indictment for are plead guilty
to conspiracy to commit prostitution and
money laundering fares plea agreement
says he may be called upon to testify
and he may have information that may
help the feds go after lacy and Larkin
they were in prison for about a week the
government didn't want to let them out
on bail but they were eventually led on
a million dollar bail apiece and now
they've got these GPS trackers that they
have to wear around their ankles and
they're not allowed to leave Maricopa
County first thing they did after they
did the house seizures is they seized
all our bank accounts froze all our bank
accounts also when after our lawyers
accounts froze those seized some of them
they tried to disqualify our First
Amendment lawyers because they know that
the First Amendment is what we stand for
well we've always stood behind and we
intend to do that in this case as well
it's a very difficult situation and
that's the way they want it they have
all the power in the world
[Music]
there was just a lot of fear too in the
sex burger community when this happened
these are not the most high-end sex
workers who maybe have a huge you know
backup that are posting on Backpage this
is the people we're just getting by
online resources for sex workers were
disappearing a bill called FASTA the
fight online sex trafficking act had
recently passed in Congress creating an
exception to section 230 making
platforms responsible for third-party
content so now it's not just the feds
who could take Internet service
providers to court if anyone under age
uses them or if anyone uses them to
facilitate forced prostitution but now
anyone can sue them in civil court for
this and all 50 state attorney general
could bring criminal charges against
them basta then also makes it a separate
federal crime for digital platforms to
facilitate prostitution and the owner or
manager or operator of some of these
services can be punished up to 25 years
in prison even when it's only between
consenting adults and there's no sex
trafficking happening it had a chilling
effect on sex worker resources
Craigslist then closed it's even dating
section because it got worried that the
dating ads may accidentally facilitate
prostitution you've had reddit closed
sex worker forums where they were just
talking amongst themselves not taken
down by the government take you down
proactively by the website operators
because now they're afraid to let sex
workers pretty much speak about anything
because they're afraid of getting in
trouble for facilitating prostitution
it's these crazy unintended consequences
that again make people in the sex trade
less safe without the ability to have
simple affordable access to an online
platform that allows you to put space
time and scrutiny you are making
decisions that are precarious I've heard
reports in my community of people who
are you know choosing to see clients
that have assaulted them because money
is tight rent is real I heard a report
from a girl on social media that I
followed up with that said in the days
that Backpage fell at one point she was
hit up by five different pimps within
three hours the people it's like oh yeah
well you can't afford to post an ad
that's okay baby I've got clients for
you I mean that's real life that's what
people like me are facing right now it's
not hypothetical it's real some deputies
are now expecting more prostitutes on
streets looking for customers in what's
become a buyers market
you obviously have seen in just
anecdotally from a lot of sex workers
that there are a lot of people who have
gone back to the streets and you also
see a range of new websites popping up
to try and fill this void the Austin
Police Department's human trafficking
unit is slowing down pausing some of its
investigations after the website back
page was shut down back page going down
it's harder for investigators ended like
catch up to the crime now they have to
find out where it is happening next it's
that whack-a-mole thing I have a couple
good friends who are survivors of
trafficking and work in the
anti-trafficking world to serve victims
work with law enforcement and they say
you've taken our evidence away those ads
were evidence to find victims it's not
about the kids it's not about the
victims this is about people creating
careers building names for themselves
and you know Michael Lacy and Jim Larkin
are just the poster boys these
individuals must be held accountable
these allegations must be given voice
and we have to do all that is right to
make sure that we as a civil society
protect always the most vulnerable among
us and not take advantage of them
assuming nobody will care these hearings
have made clear we care so many
different people put on this huge show
of making them the villain in this at
the same time every time that you have
things like providing more money
directly to shelters for homeless teens
or for sex trafficking victims come up
for votes in these states and federal
legislators nobody votes for it every
time you have these things that offer
direct material assistance to victims
nobody votes for it every time it's
about Morcar serration or more money for
awareness and government-funded studies
and task forces and stuff they vote for
that back Page has enabled them to keep
pretending like they're fighting sex
trafficking while actually doing very
little no one cares about sex
trafficking victims more than the
community where they come from and
that's the sex working community and and
what I'm angry about is that you know
like piss in my mouth but don't tell me
it's raining right like criminalized the
industry throw us in jail but don't tell
me because it's your it's your cuz
you're trying to save us and make it
better and make it more safe you know I
think that's what's most insulting about
this whole can of worms
[Music]
and as we embark on this campaign I will
tell you this I am not perfect lord
knows I am not perfect but I will always
speak with decency and moral clarity and
treat all people with dignity and
respect
[Applause]
Backpage was providing advertisement for
the sale of children of miners and
unlike craigslist which said we're gonna
stop doing it the people who are running
back page basically thumb their nose at
us
exist kissed her ass see that's their
definition of the right thing that's
what she means when she said we thumbed
her nose at them we don't think it's the
government's job to be telling us what
to print it's hard to make us feel
guilty
we're not guilty okay okay you can't you
can't talk me into it
we didn't cal tell we don't tell tell it
would give the lie to our entire lives
our entire career of being journalists
if the government could come in and put
their stubby little fingers in our chest
and make us ask for our mommy ain't
going to happen
[Music]
you